there has been a surge in fighting
between Ukrainian government forces and
pro-russian rebels with both sides
pushing to make gains ahead of today's
peace talks in Minsk we spoke to
ambassador william harrison Courtney a
Russia expert and senior fellow at the
RAND Corporation also in Washington well
the Russians seem to be wanting to
expand the area that they have
controlled they now have maybe 500
square kilometers additional beyond what
was agreed in September in the ceasefire
talks in Minsk so it looks like they
want to change the correlation of forces
and now revised the ceasefire record
partly because they want to gain control
or a strategic real Hobbit about social
the Ukrainian military forces have been
fighting fairly courageously but do not
well-armed and so after the September
ceasefire coordinates the Russians and
the rebels that they back decided to
continue the offensive because
apparently opinions did not offer enough
opposition from their perspective and so
it's not clear whether if a new game is
negotiated whether there will be any
more stable or go on agreed and
September because the mismatch of forces
between Russia and Ukraine will still be
as great as it was then why is letting a
pluton pushing so hard in the Eastern
boombox well in Crimea they have an
incentive because the russian black sea
fleet is based there and russia was
always uneasy with that lease
arrangement with Ukraine they took
Crimea in a bloodless seizure last last
year and that seemed to give the Kremlin
some feeling of being emboldened and so
they decided to go after the eastern
dome Boston area which has industrial
activity which is important to Russia
but at that point they didn't have
strategic surprise so they've taken
quite a few casualties there and they're
still taking more casuals it's not clear
how far they want to go that's the big
uncertainty earlier where Putin talked
about novarossi at an area that would
all the way down to Odessa including
Odessa as being part of sort of Russia
in a natural sense some have argued in
Russia that maybe something less than
but a land bridge from the eastern
Ukraine all the way down to Crimea would
be important to be able to support
Crimea it's a little bit unclear now how
far they want to go where they are right
now is they're about to completely
encircle the vaults of Otis railhead on
the northern edge of sfc but the next
logical target would lead to take on
Mary opal re opals the city ten times
the size of divisive if they decided to
go after Mario book it would be a huge
bloody assault and I think the Russians
probably thinking very hard whether they
want to run the risks of doing that up
to now the Kremlin has been telling its
own people that Russian forces are not
fighting in Ukraine if they mount an
assault Mario blow which is so large
they will be hard for the Kremlin to
maintain that friction in Russia